it is great to welcome to the program
today andrew sullivan who's a blogger at
the weekly dish his book now out in
paperback is out on a limb collected
writing from 1989 to 2021 you know
andrew it's so great to have you on
because as a progressive my very
left-wing audience will say
who on the right is interesting to
listen to because i'm not getting what i
need intellectually from matt gates for
example
and i will often say you know i actually
think andrew sullivan writes a lot of
really interesting things but the the
strange thing is
i see very little in common at this
point between you and sort of where the
american republican party is i mean do
you do you feel like you still see your
politics in that party
i've never seen my politics
in that political party
um never identified as a republican
have
been pretty
hostile to successive republican
presidents i mean
bush and trump for example
a big supporter of obama no my
my view is really from a more english
conservative position
of limited government of free society
um skepticism about grand
changes to society in general
and a belief in the west and its core
values and
and that meant that i did not have a
huge problem for example
in supporting barack obama whom i
regarded as a bit of a moderate a bit of
an old school actually
i always thought of him as a 1970s kind
of republican um
and so i i don't fit in is the truth but
i am definitely not a lefty and i'm
definitely not
uh
a liberal in the progressive sense i uh
i'm a skeptic of those those traditions
when you look at
to pick something specific
the increased willingness from the
modern american right wing
to use government power to achieve
whatever it is they're looking to
achieve rather than stepping back into
what might be called small government
conservatism doing the absolute least
does that concern you above and beyond
just you know whether you identify with
the movement or not because it's
antithetical to the way you believe
governments should operate or is it is
it not as brought a concern as some more
traditional conservatives point out
i think that
at some level you know the right in
terms of the culture war particularly
does have a right to self-defense i mean
i and i don't think that's completely
outrageous i don't think it's outrageous
for example that
we should have states decide what their
abortion regime is going to be through
democratic processes i i i don't think
it's
crazy for a state
for example to look at its own
educational curriculum and positions and
if it's that has been altered
dramatically in ways that the
the politics of the state doesn't quite
accept then i don't think it's out of
bounds
for a governor or school boards to do
within the classic democratic tradition
a change of policy or a reversal of
policy uh
but i do think there's a sense of using
the state as a wielding sort of a weapon
to punish people
uh so for example let me give you a
desantis
uh he's perfectly within his rights to
say
no in in florida we are going to through
the legislature change
uh curriculum and and pass this this law
it's another thing
for him then to use the power of the
governor to punish a company disney for
disagreeing with him see there's a
distinction there and i think sometimes
uh it can get muddled up i don't think
the right has to constantly disarm but i
do think the right has lost a sense of
the limits of government
the need to let society evolve on its
own and to be
tolerant of other points of view and
allow them their place in the sun and
that that goes for both sides by the way
and i think a great deal of the uh
pushback
from the right on some of these culture
issues is a response to aggressive acts
by the progressive left when it comes to
democratically deciding abortion law at
the state level like you mentioned
kansas had an actual
vote of the people of the population
other states like indiana its
legislators who got together and said
we're banning it after i think six weeks
is the latest proposal with very very
few exceptions one could argue that
that's democratic in the sense that
it's legislators elected by the people
who are deciding that but it runs
counter to public opinion as best we can
tell at this point in time so are both
of those examples of democratically
deciding or is only when the people vote
an example of that
well i think the kansas thing was a very
particular
question because they'd already had some
sort of uh
decision barring uh
that made some kind of vote yes as a
referendum inevitable
no no i don't think it really matters
how that democracy is pursued it may be
that in the short term for example there
are lots of people in republicans
elected estate legislatures who are more
to the right on abortion than most of
their voters are absolutely well vote
them out or
or or let your views be known to them
to make sure they're not following some
pre-existing ideological commitment
which you know for many years it was so
easy for republicans to say i'm for
batting all abortion period and they
would never called on it because there
were no one was ever going to be
enforcing it now that it's having to be
enforced i think you're going to get
actual real compromises and decisions
that are made state by state and i think
liberals or pro-life brew choices in
general
are way too pessimistic about their
chances in that process and i think
we'll probably end up in the us
pretty not that far away
from many countries in western europe
and although we will have some outliers
on the conservative front but you know
america is more conservative than parts
of europe and i i i don't have a problem
with states coming to different
positions on questions like that the
other because we're talking about a lot
of cultural and social issues it was
notable to me
i've sort of seen this building and look
in watching trump rallies over the last
year to 18 months but it was very
notable at cpac
that the biggest applause lines were the
more overtly homophobic and transphobic
lines jokes about pronouns uh you know i
i don't have the full list in front of
me but when you saw the crowd really get
excited they were dead when trump was
talking about himself as the biggest
victim in the history of the western of
western civilization that did not excite
the crowd too much but the stuff about
trans swimmers and ted cruz's pronouns
and there it really excited the crowd do
you agree that there's been a sort of
resurgence of that sentiment in the
modern american right and are you
concerned about it
i think i am within some
aspects of the conservative right i mean
we're talking about the texas cpac so we
are talking about the pretty hardcore
fanatics and they are so polarized that
anything
pro-gay for example gets attacked but
when you actually look at the polling
data of regular republicans you now see
a majority of republicans favoring
marriage equality what i do think you're
seeing uh is a
an understandable response
to a very aggressive push
by essentially uh
gender
uh
queer and gender critical theorists to
redefine what sex is to redefine what
gender is and to teach those
redefinitions to three to four-year-olds
without their parents even being
informed and i think that has led to a
backlash i honestly think it's
understandable it's led to a backlash
and there are plenty of us who are very
supportive of gay and trans rights who
are not
nonetheless wedded to this rather
postmodern understanding the biological
sex is basically non-existent that you
pick and choose whichever gender you
have and that there are more than 55
different genders to pick from and all
of them trump sex in every particular
instance i don't buy any of that and i
think insofar as there's been resistance
to it
it's been a function of the left
overreaching rather than the right uh
demonstrating its its intolerance that's
not to say i defend some of this stuff
well i mean
some of the ugly some of the things you
just said i'm also against i've just not
seen them being taught to four-year-olds
anywhere i mean where and i'm not saying
this rhetorically like where are they
teaching four-year-olds that there is no
biological basis at all for gender and
that there's 55 choices to be i just
haven't seen that
well um i recommend you check a couple
pieces i've done recently at the weekly
dish on this
um state curricula are now mandating
places that were as in florida as in new
jersey and there are other places
with that gender identity and homosexual
and sexual orientation be taught from
kindergarten onwards now how that is
translated
is a different question but i can also
show you plenty of children's books
plenty of lesson plans in which this is
uh argued for as early as three or four
and what they say of of course they're
not using words like biological sex or
they're saying and this is the phrase
that comes across
uh quite starkly to me
you this is this is to a childhood
kindergarten you can be a boy or a girl
or both or neither or something else
entirely and it's up to you to choose
well i don't i honestly i i think
telling three-year-olds that before they
even wrap their heads around boy and
girl
uh seems to me
outrageously over the top and certainly
not something a lot of gay people even
think should be taught and certainly
affects gay kids who themselves
have a slightly different perspective
which is that yes we're boys
but we just happen to be attracted to
other boys now they may not be they will
not be aware of that in any real sense
at three four five i don't see there's a
problem with restricting it to kids who
were eight years old or above and i
don't think that's some sort of fascist
move i think that i think the ideologues
got out of control and they're being uh
slightly reigned back in and i i don't
think that's the end of the world
yeah i mean it's hard for me to respond
substantively because i just haven't
seen what you're describing so i'll do
some research on that i think as books
yeah they're really
they're they're ways in which you
translate it
uh to children and i think it can be
rather disorienting
for children to be taught this that
young
as a political question what would you
like to see the american right whether
it's through the republican party or
outside of it wherever you you follow it
what should be the substance of the
platforms on which those candidates run
because especially in the trump era
they don't even really pretend to be
about economic policy they'll vaguely
talk about taxes and regulation but
there's very little substance there
uh there i like what substance is it
this stuff the stuff about what
four-year-olds are taught because that
seems sort of flimsy as well as a
platform
it is flimsy as a platform um but i do
think there is a potent policy mix
that's on the table
and that is for the republican party to
go left on economics
to do things like supporting like take
the pro-life position if they actually
got their act together and decided to
really fund health care for
pregnant women uh that they actually did
put some beef behind support for
bringing children into the world
along with more restrictions on abortion
then i think they'd have much a fairer
hearing at least uh and i think moving
left on economics in terms of trade i
think uh moving right on
immigration
and that combination with a certain
amount of cultural not right wingery but
conservatism in the sense that we don't
really want to redefine gender we don't
want to suddenly decide that everyone uh
has to overcome uh whiteness in order to
become a fully functioning member of
society those kinds of things i think
that's a very potent
uh platform it's potent in europe and it
would be potent here if it hadn't been
consumed by all this awful authoritarian
instincts by the cult worship of trump
by the
anti-institutional
anti-conservative radicalism
of many of these groups
and
i i think there is a center there a
center right that will be
made anew in the new world around
nationalism around trade around
immigration but that could be sane
and would work very well and
unfortunately i think the republican
party seems
currently incapable of coming up with
that is there anybody right now that
embodies that i mean who when you i know
you don't like trump my guess is you're
not big on desantis is are there people
currently in politics in the u.s that
match this ideology that you're talking
about
well look desantis has a certain edge to
him and he's he's posing as trump
essentially at this point yes but when
you look at his early time in florida
when you look at for example he's been
quite sensible and pragmatic on climate
change in terms of resilience in florida
he's been doing quite a lot of
sane stuff on the environment
i think if you could get past the the
personality cult of someone like trump
and i think if you could start
delivering so for example if trump had
actually delivered on his wall even
though he didn't i do think you could
have a more successful presidency than
you did with trump but trump
is just suey generous he is a crazy
person
he has attacked this country's
institutions and its democracy he should
not be anywhere near political office so
from my point of view unless that is
resolved
we can support i can't support anything
republican but if a republican were to
emerge he would actually
acknowledge and recognize our
constitutional order
he can reform the institutions but not
destroy them
and
create a policy agenda that is more left
economically a more right socially then
that's a perfectly decent outcome for
the future of the right in america the
question is who can do it i think to be
honest with you i have an open mind
about whether desantis is that person or
whether he is not that person
uh and we'll see
people like mitt romney and liz cheney
how what's your perspective on them
i i
i have what we call newfound respect for
liz cheney i do think that what she's
done has required courage and integrity
and i think she's right i really do
i think mitt romney's move on supporting
family life and the economic stresses of
young families with kids who are
struggling to get by
is also
very positive um i hope
i it seems to me that until we get rid
of trump someone like liz chaney is not
going to be a player but
she's got a long life and we don't know
what happens but i'm i'm very happy i
said about you but when i look back at
my worry about romney in 2012 i'm like
jesus give me romney any day of the week
now he would be far preferable to these
these nut balls and he's
he's a good guy you know at some point
just someone who respects the rule of
law
and the constitution and says so
publicly is such a relief on the
republican side no i know what you mean
i recently rewatched this netflix
documentary about romney's i believe it
was the 2012 run
and without
you know rehabilitating his policies
specifically which i preferred obama at
the time but it's hard to feel like it
would have been a crisis if mitt romney
had won in 2012 in the way that we've
seen in the last four years because he
seems so comparatively benign and
inoffensive
there are two things here you can
disagree with someone's policies yeah
that's what democracy is right right
vote for the other guy but when you lose
trust in that person's respect for the
system for the institutions and for the
rule of law it's something else entirely
we since trump became the nominee we've
been a different world we have been in a
democratic emergency because this is
someone at the center of our system who
despises our system and who will seek to
undermine it doesn't even understand it
so
putting that aside it would be lovely to
get back
to a really good debate about policy
right how do we best protect the
environment you know i mean and the
current bill for example
is a bit of a hodgepodge isn't it but
it's a decent hodgepodge it's a
compromise that moves things forward
and i the same with abortion in the
states even though you may hate the idea
it's being done it's still a process a
political process find a compromise move
things forward in a way and that's all
liberal democracy should be about we're
not about solving every human problem
we're about making things a bit better
if we can
and i want to kind of dial back
these existential claims about what
politics can do
and get back to
the difficult unsatisfying but
absolutely
phenomenally important
compromising legislating and i think
that the current congress
after a rough start has begun to hit its
stride on that i agree i will be i'll be
very interested to see how the public
responds yeah because i think the public
wants this i really do
even though it won't solve everything it
shows that we can do something
and i hope i hope that's rewarded yeah
and some of the polling data over the
last two months suggests that uh
things are looking different for a
midterm than than they would
historically be expected to look we'll
have to wait two and a half months now
and see
um the book now out in paperback is out
on a limb collected writing from 89 to
2021 we've been speaking with blogger
andrew sullivan who's work you can read
at the weekly dish so great having you
on
thanks so much for for having this
conversation i i'm i'm really really
grateful to be part of it